Salut la team Mentalo !
J'adore arriver en sautant.
Aujourd'hui, je vous donne une méthode
pour trouver à quoi pense une personne.
Cette technique de mentalisme
ressemble un peu au Cumberlandisme,
mais attention, c'est pas du Cumberlandisme.
Que ce soit bien clair.
Mais c'est vrai que ça y ressemble quand même.
Concrètement,
on va choisir dans un stock d'informations
une manière de faire une dichotomie,
ou en tout cas de séquencer l'information
pour avoir des réponses du type "oui" ou "non".
Et pour accéder aux pensées de la personne,
vous allez simplement lui tenir les mains..
..juste lui tenir les deux mains.
Dans cette vidéo,
je donne toute la méthode pour faire ça.
Je vous ai fait aussi une vidéo de démonstration.
En tout cas, je vais la faire.
J'ai quelqu'un qui passe à la maison tout à l'heure.
On va filmer la démo que je vais mettre ici.
Je ne sais pas encore à quoi ça ressemble
puisque je ne l'ai pas encore fait.
Et ça me permettra
d'être un petit plus concis dans les explications.
Et vous pourrez cliquer là.
C'est une vidéo non-répertoriée
qui se trouve également dans le descriptif.
- Mais il a pensé à tout !
- Et bah oui on essaie.
Vous prenez les deux mains
de la personne en face de vous.
Une distance normale, vous pouvez être assis
ou debout, ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance.
Et donc vous lui tenez les mains comme ça.
Je prends l'exemple du jeu de cartes,
car tout à l'heure je vais le faire avec un jeu de cartes.
Comme ça on aura 52 possibilités.
Ça pourrait être n'importe quelle liste
où vous pouvez séquencer
n'importe quel mot qui fait partie d'un ensemble.
Après forcément, ça augmente le processus.
Bon pour 52 cartes...
Vous prenez les mains de la personne
et vous lui demandez
de différencier ses 2 mains.
l'une des mains sera "oui",
l'autre des mains sera "non".
Ça, c'est l'étape la plus importante,
elle est essentielle.
Si par exemple la personne a une montre,
je demande de focaliser sur la montre
et je lui dis que cette montre là, ce sera le "non"
ou le "oui".
D'ailleurs peu importe.
Mais il faut que ce soit très clair pour la personne
de savoir à quelle main elle dit "oui"
et à quelle main elle dit "non".
S'il y a un joli bijou sur une main,
vous pouvez dire : "Alors cette main là ce sera le oui.
Souviens toi le bijou, c'est beau, c'est oui."
Je reprends les 2 mains que j'ai fait tomber.
- Mais elles sont invisibles.
- Mais c'est pas grave.
Et vous lui demandez juste de se concentrer,
de vous répondre uniquement par oui ou par non
tout le temps.
Mais quand la réponse est oui,
de concentrer toute son énergie mentale.
Oui l'énergie mentale,
ça veut rien dire on est bien d'accord,
mais n'empêche en disant ce mot là,
le processus fonctionne mieux.
En fait, la personne
doit diriger l'ensemble de ses pensées
et se focaliser sur la main Oui
si elle pense "oui"
et sur la main Non si elle pense "non."
Et vous allez bouger les 2 mains comme ça,
sans poser de questions au départ, évidemment.
Donc les mains sont relativement molles
et ça va habituer le mouvement.
Et vous commencez à parler à la personne
en lui posant des questions simples,
des questions dont vous connaissez la réponse.
Je m'appelle Fabien.
C'est pas vraiment une question d'ailleurs,
vous faites des affirmations,
et elle, elle dit oui ou non dans sa tête.
Donc je m'appelle Fabien, je m'appelle Fabien.
On est chez moi en ce moment,
on est chez moi en ce moment.
J'ai un tee-shirt avec un escargot,
j'ai un tee-shirt avec un escargot.
Ça va vous permettre de commencer
à ressentir un petit peu,
comme dans le cumberlandisme.
C'est pas forcément un calibrage,
mais ça vous permet
de ressentir un petit peu les réactions.
Parce que c'est très simple,
à chaque fois que la personne
va se focaliser sur la main,
alors dans ce cas là,
elle va oublier l'autre main.
Donc la main...
négative, dirons nous,
va devenir un petit peu molle
alors que la main positive,
la main où la personne est concentrée
va avoir un petit peu plus de résistance
et c'est là où tout est le secret.
Donc pour reprendre l'exemple du jeu de cartes.
Pour les familles vous faites...
C'est du pique, c'est du pique, c'est du pique,
c'est du cœur, c'est du cœur,
c'est du carreau, c'est du carreau,
c'est du trèfle, c'est du trèfle...
De temps en temps, vous pouvez aussi feinter
pour revenir sur des questions plus basiques,
un peu comme celles de calibrage au départ
parce que ça remet un petit peu les choses en place.
Mais pour tout ça,
il y a la démo qui est là.
L'important,
c'est que vous ayez compris le principe
et que vous puissiez essayer.
Alors forcément,
c'est un petit peu comme pour tout,
il faut répéter un petit peu quoi,
il faut s'entraîner.
Osez rater pour après mieux réussir
et après avoir un acquis
et savoir le faire sur tout quand vous voulez.
Si vous avez une question là-dessus,
c'est dans les commentaires que ça se passe.
Vous pouvez vous répondre entre vous
et puis moi aussi je passe,
de toute manière,
je lis toujours tous les commentaires.
Je sais qu'on s'approche très dangereusement
des 100 000
au moment où je fais cette vidéo-là,
où je suis en train de l'enregistrer...
Je n'ai pas oublié ce que j'ai dit
dans la 1ère FAQ de la chaîne,
à l'époque où on était que 700.
Et j'ai pris un engagement devant vous,
que je respecterai.
Je suis déjà en train de réfléchir
à comment ça va se faire.
Et je ne prendrai plus d'engagement à la légère.
Voilà, j'espère vraiment que cette vidéo vous aura plu.
Vous pouvez laisser un pouce en l'air
parce que ça c'est cool.
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne
puisque quand même le MentalVlog, il faut le dire,
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre.
Rendez-vous demain à 17 h.
Ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre
à la Garenne-Colombes.
C'est la date la plus proche de Paris
si jamais vous voulez venir.
Sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site.